we've got an incredible woman to tell
you about the washington post reports
that a teacher in virginia named
jennifer williams has made it her
personal mission to give away one
million books to kids for free
[Applause]
the book lady has already given away 90
500 books spending tens of thousands of
dollars of her own money and she teaches
fifth grade and tutors on the side to
make it all happen she brings books to
students at schools and stocks local
libraries and you know builds boxes and
those little like house things i love
those i have one of those in my
neighborhood take a book leave a book
yeah yeah there's one right there and
jennifer says i'm having books at home
can make all the difference in
developing vocabulary and communication
skills and i will say jennifer that i am
completely self-taught and it is totally
from books so i'm i commend you i thank
you and keep up the good work thank you
thank you thank you that's amazing well
next up we've got some good news for the
old taste buds it's booty
[Applause]
oh that's sammy sullivan
doing the num nom noms what is this so
the world's ice cream scientists have
done it again and this time they've
turned churros into ice cream raising
hands who likes churros
oh what is it about those delightful
ropes of sugar it's my kryptonite sugar
i will do anything for a churro do you
understand well dolce de leche churro is
the latest flavor from haagen-dazs and
um i just had to try it and let
everybody know about this new concoction
that's available okay let's do
god
oh my god
okay
okay i it tastes so specifically
something and i'm wondering churros
it's a churro but it's the cinnamon
toast crunch of it all you know what i
mean it's like in the bottom of the bowl
with the milk and the yum and
i mean
i really just a little recommendation go
pick yourself a pint of dulce de leche
okay yeah
absolutely we're the taste testers and i
think we give it a five star review can
i give it ten yes
we've got an incredible woman to tell
you about the washington post reports
that a teacher in virginia named
jennifer williams has made it her
personal mission to give away one
million books to kids for free
amazing book lady has already given away
90
500 books spending tens of thousands of
dollars of her own money and she teaches
fifth grade and tutors on the side to
make it all happen she brings books to
students at schools and stocks local
libraries and you know
builds boxes and those little like house
things i love those i have one of those
in my neighborhood take a book leave a
book yeah yeah there's one right there
and jennifer says um having books at
home can make all the difference in
developing vocabulary and communication
skills and i will say jennifer that i am
completely self-taught and it is totally
from books so i'm i commend you i thank
you and keep up the good work thank you
thank you thank you that's amazing well
next up we've got some good news for the
old taste buds it's food
[Applause]
oh that's sammy sullivan
doing the num nom noms what is this so
the world's ice cream scientists have
done it again and this time they've
turned churros into ice cream raising
pants who likes churros
oh what is it about those delightful
ropes of sugar it's my kryptonite sugar
i will do anything for a churro do you
understand well dolce de leche churro is
the latest flavor from haagen-dazs
and um i just had to try it and let
everybody know about this new concoction
that's available okay let's do
god
oh my god
okay
okay i it tastes so specifically
something and i'm wondering churros
it's a churro but it's the cinnamon
toast crunch of it all you know what i
mean it's like in the bottom of the bowl
with the milk and the yum and
i mean i really just a little
recommendation go pick yourself a pint
of dulce de leche
yeah
absolutely we're the taste testers and i
think we give it a five star review can
i give it ten
[Music]
you